half of the human workforce is expected
to be replaced by software and robots in
the next 20 years and many corporate
leaders welcome that as a chance to
increase profits machines are more
efficient humans are complicated and
difficult to manage well I want our
organizations to remain human in fact I
want them to become beautiful because as
machines take our jobs and do them more
efficiently soon the only work left for
us humans will be the kind of work that
must be done beautifully rather than
efficiently to maintain our humanity in
this second Machine Age we may have no
other choice than to create beauty
beauty is an elusive concept for the
writers dental it was the promise of
happiness for me it's a goal by Leona
messy so bear with me as I'm proposing
for admittedly very subjective
principles that you can use to build a
beautiful organization first do the
unnecessary a few months ago Hamdi
Ulukaya the CEO and founder of the yoga
company Chobani made headlines when he
decided to grant stock to all of his
2,000 employees some called it a PR
stunt others a genuine act of giving
back but there was something else that
was remarkable about it it came
completely out of the blue there had
been no market or stakeholder pressure
and employees were so surprised that
they burst into tears when they heard
the news actions like eluc ayahs are
beautiful because they catch us off
guard they create something out of
nothing because they're completely
unnecessary I once worked at a company
that was the result of a merger of a
large IT outsourcing firm and a small
design firm we were merging 9,000
software engineers were
one thousand creative types and to unify
these immensely different cultures we
were going to launch a third new brand
and the new brand color was going to be
orange and as we were going through the
budget for the rollout we decided last
minute to cut the purchase of 10000
orange balloons which we had meant to
distribute to all staff worldwide they
just seemed unnecessary and cute in the
end I didn't know back then that our
decision marked the beginning of the end
that these two organizations would never
become one and sure enough the merger
eventually failed now was it because
there weren't any orange balloons no of
course not but the kill the orange
balloons mentality permeated everything
else you might not always realize it but
when you cut the unnecessary you cut
everything leading with beauty means
rising above what is merely necessary so
do not kill your orange balloons
the second principle create intimacy
studies show that how we feel about a
workplace very much depends on the
relationships with our co-workers and
what our relationships other than a
string of micro interactions there are
hundreds of these every day in our
organizations that have the potential to
distinguish a good life from a beautiful
one the marriage researcher John Gottman
says that the secret of a healthy
relationship is not the great gesture or
the lofty promise it's small moments of
attachment in other words intimacy in
our networked organizations we tout the
strength of weak ties but we
underestimate the strength of strong
ones we forget the words of the writer
Richard Baca once said
intimacy not connectedness intimacy is
the opposite of loneliness so how do we
design for organizational intimacy the
humanitarian organization care I wanted
to launch a campaign on gender equality
in villages in northern India but it
realized quickly that it had to have
this conversation first with its own
staff
so it invited all 36 team members and
their partners to one of the hadoo
hollow temples known for their famous
erotic sculptures and there they openly
discuss their personal relationships
their own experiences of gender equality
with the co-workers and the partners it
was eye-opening for the participants not
only did it allow them to relate to the
communities they serve
it also broke down invisible barriers
and created a lasting bond amongst
themselves not a single team member quit
in the next four years so this is how
you create intimacy no masks or lots of
masks when Dan owned the food company
wanted to translate its new company
manifesto into product initiatives it
gathered the management team and 100
employees from across different
departments seniority levels and regions
for a three-day strategy retreat and it
asked everybody to wear costumes for the
entire meeting wigs crazy hats feather
boas huge glasses and so on and they
left with concrete outcomes and full of
enthusiasm and when I asked a woman who
had designed this experience why'd work
she simply said never underestimate the
power of a ridiculous wig
because wigs erase hierarchy and
hierarchy kilts intimacy both ways for
the CEO and the intern weeks allow us to
use the disguise of the Falls to show
something true about ourselves and
that's not easy in our everyday work
lives because the relationship with our
organizations is often like that of a
married couple that has grown apart
suffered betrayals and disappointments
and is now desperate to be beautiful for
one another once again and for either of
us the first step toward beauty involves
a huge risk the risk to be ugly so many
organizations these days are keen on
designing beautiful workplaces that look
like anything bad work vacation resorts
coffee shops playgrounds or college
campuses based on the promises of
positive psychology we speak of play and
gamification and one startup even says
that when someone gets fired they have
graduated that kind of beautiful
language only goes skin deep but oddly
cuts clean to the bone as the writer
Dorothy Parker once put it to be
authentic is to be ugly it doesn't mean
that you can't have fun or you must give
in to the vulgar or cynical but it does
mean that you speak the actual ugly
truth like this manufacturer that wanted
to transform one of its struggling
business units it identified named and
pinned on large boards all the issues
there were hundreds of them that had
become obstacles to better performance
it put them on boards moved them all
into one room which had called the ugly
room the ugly became visible for
everyone to see it was celebrated and
the ugly room served as a mix of mirror
exhibition and operating room a biopsy
on the living flesh to cut out all the
bureaucracy the obvious part of our body
is our brain literally and
neurologically our brain renders ugly
what is unfamiliar modern art eight
music jazz maybe VR goggles for that
matter strange object sounds and people
but we've all been ugly once we were a
weird-looking baby a new kid on the blog
a foreigner and we will be ugly again
when we don't belong the Center for
political beauty an activist collective
in Berlin recently staged an extreme
artistic intervention with the
permission of relatives it excuses of
refugees who had drowned at Europe's
borders transported them all the way to
Berlin and then reburied them at the
heart of the German capital the idea was
to allow them to reach the desired
destination if only after their death
such acts of beautification may not be
pretty but they are much-needed because
things tend to get ugly when there's
only one meaning one truth only answers
and no questions
beautiful organisations keep asking
questions they remain incomplete which
is the fourth and the last of the
principles recently I was in Paris and a
friend of mine took me to nuit debout
which stands for up all night the self
organized protest movement that had
formed in response to the proposed labor
laws in France every night hundreds
gathered at the Place de la Republique
every night they set up a small
temporary village to deliberate their
own vision of the French Republic and at
the core of this adhocracy was a General
Assembly where anybody could speak using
a specially designed sign language like
Occupy Wall Street and other protest
movements nuit debout was born in the
face of crisis it was messy full of
controversies and contradictions but
whether you agreed with the movements
goals or not every gathering was a
beautiful lesson in raw humanity and how
fitting at Paris the city of ideals the
city of beauty was its stage it reminds
us that like great cities the most
beautiful organization are ideas worth
fighting for even and especially when
the outcome is uncertain
they are movements they're always
imperfect never fully organized so they
avoid ever becoming banal they have
something but we don't know what it is
they remain mysterious we can take our
eyes of them we find them beautiful so
to do the unnecessary to create intimacy
to be ugly to remain incomplete these
are not only the qualities of beautiful
organizations these are inherently human
characteristics and these are also the
qualities of what we call home and as we
disrupt and are disrupted the least we
can do is to ensure that we still feel
at home in our organizations and that we
use our organizations to create that
feeling for others beauty can save the
world when we embrace these principles
and designed for them in the face of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning we need a new radical humanism
we must acquire and promote a new
aesthetic and sentimental education
because if we don't we might end up
feeling like aliens and organizations
and societies that are full of smart
machines that has no appreciation
whatsoever for the unnecessary the
intimate the incomplete and definitely
not for the ugly thank